these documents are full of confidential
information detailing the work of the
inquiry into child sex abuse it includes
the names of survivors and the role
they've been playing last week it was
leaked to a committee of MPs chaired by
Keith Vaz now we've learned they decided
to put it all online we have the
document and we will be publishing it as
you say best to publish all these on the
website so they will be on the website
this afternoon I think we've just
published them we've also published a
series of emails although the survivors
had already revealed themselves as
victims of abuse the leaked documents
includes sensitive information and they
say it's put them in danger it's
obviously very distressing and quite
worrying to be targeted in this way but
I know that I am one of very many that
have been targeted as campaigners and
even as other professionals that are
working in this field oh this
transparency and then there's a breach
of the Data Protection Act and and I
think that's something for mr. Vaz to
ask himself and to question within the
home affairs select committee the
committee has now redacted their names
and other confidential details we've
learned that Home Secretary Theresa May
wrote to Keith Vaz asking him to
apologise in a statement he said last
week some material from the independent
panel inquiry into child sexual abuse
came to the committee's possession in
the course of our inquiry at the request
of individuals concerned the material
has been redacted to remove references
to these individuals the names of these
individuals were already in the public
domain some survivors have called for
the inquiry to be scrapped altogether
and a new statutory inquiry created is
currently without a chair after last
year Baroness Butler's loss and then
Fiona Woolf were both forced to step
down after their links with
establishment figures came to light it's
been a shambles it is a shambles one has
to begin to question if it's all
entirely coincidental there is a lot of
vested interest that doesn't want things
about prominent people coming out these
documents
have breached the confidence of
individual survivors but it's trust in
the inquiry as a whole that has taken
the biggest hit ever her Sh Sky News